First appearing in 1986 on a highway between
the city of Caracas and its airport, La Mancha
Negra, meaning literally a black stain, began
as an approximately 50-yard (46 meter) long
smudge, seen by highway workers who were resurfacing
the road with asphalt concrete.
Ultimately the spot grew to cover about an
8 mile (13 km) stretch.
In 1991 it was widely reported that the slippery
goo had caused over 1,800 deaths and countless
other injuries.
So what is it and is it still there today?
Many hypotheses have been proposed over the
years as to the cause of La Mancha Negra,
such as that it’s the result of raw sewage
from slums that line the road, with the idea
being the sewage runs downhill and under the
asphalt where it mixes with the compounds
in the road, breaking it down and producing
the slippery, chewing gum like substance.
Another popular theory is that oil and other
fluids from old, rickety cars produce the
goo when mixed with the dust of the roadway.
Conspiracy theorists proposed it’s an intentional,
regular sabotage by certain political powers
to turn the public against the government
leaders.
Authorities reportedly tried a number of remedies
in the mid-1990s to remove the goo, including
pressure washing it with detergents and simply
scraping the goo off in layers.
All attempts to get rid of the substance were
reportedly in vain, though it’s noted that
each attempt made a hefty profit for the company
in charge of the removal of the substance
and there was some question as to how hard
they were actually trying.
As a last ditch effort, authorities finally
decided to dump pulverized limestone on the
goo to “dry it up”.
It seemed to work for a while, although it
produced an unwanted consequence – the limestone
was so dusty that it supposedly severely hurt
the air quality along the road for local residents
for a while after application.
So what’s the real cause of La Mancha Negra?
It was widely reported at the time that authorities
spent “millions” trying to figure out
what the substance was, but this doesn’t
seem credible.
While it is possible that millions of government
funds disappeared in the name of solving the
problem (given the rampant corruption in the
Venezuelan government at the time), no direct
evidence of any such studies seems to exist
anywhere.
Further, if any studies were done, it would
not have been expensive or difficult to determine
if the substance was the result of some sort
of asphalt / human excrement mixing.
It likewise would have been equally simple
and cheap to determine if it was car oil mixed
with dust or the like or any number of other
likely substances.
The widespread report of “1,800 deaths”
caused by the slippery road have also never
been substantiated by a credible, direct source.
One would think that an eight mile stretch
of road covered in a slippery substance would
have a higher rate of car accidents than a
normal road, but 1,800 deaths between 1986
and 1991 over that short stretch of road that
everyone knows is extremely slippery?
That’s an average of about one death per
day.
Even if the road was literally covered with
ice, this would still be a questionably high
number.
Lacking any actual evidence to support the
claim, and the news media wont to exaggerate
such figures, color me skeptical.
Further lacking anyone bothering to study
the substance, the two most plausible causes
of La Mancha Negra are, first, that it’s
just natural asphalt/bitumen seepage.
You see, Caracas lies next to the Orinoco
Belt, which contains one of the world’s
largest deposits of petroleum.
Such seepages are not unheard of in the region-
for instance at the asphalt lake, Lake Bermudez,
in Venezuela, where oil seeps to the surface
and becomes asphaltic thanks to good conditions
for oil-metabolizing bacteria to thrive.
The second, perhaps even more plausible, hypothesis
is that the La Mancha Negra phenomenon is
simply the result of using poorly mixed asphalt
concrete when constructing the road.
This second hypothesis is supported by the
fact that the goo in question seems to have
the properties of tar (chewing gum consistency,
but quite slick in certain conditions) and
that the problem gets much worse on hot days
and goes the other way on cool days.
This same phenomenon is commonly seen with
improperly mixed asphalt, generally when too
much asphalt is mixed in with the aggregate.
It’s also noted that the seepage only occurs
directly along that narrow stretch of road
(making the natural seepage hypothesis less
likely) and that the road was resurfaced with
asphalt concrete immediately before the problem
first appeared…
Putting two and two together here doesn’t
exactly seem like rocket surgery, but news
reports with titles like “Mysterious, Deadly
Goo Kills 1,800 in Venezuela” sound a lot
better than “Road Crew in Venezuela Do Crappy
Job on Eight Mile Stretch of Road.”
Further, although the phenomenon of La Mancha
Negra is widely reported as still existing
today and reported as still being very much
a mystery, all such modern reports I could
find use the original news stories from the
early 1990s as their sources.
There seem to be no further direct reports
after this or other indication that La Mancha
Negra still exists along the road in question
today.
(For what it’s worth, a simple Google Maps
satellite view of the strip in question also
seems to indicate the road has been replaced
sometime since then and there is no visual
sign that any part of the highway is different
than the highway before or after the supposed
“black stain” stretch.)
Given the lack of news reports of this still
being an issue (at least that I could find;
if you happen to be from Caracas and can provide
more insight please do in the comments below;
Google Translate can only get you so far when
looking for news reports in a language you
don’t speak :-)), it seems likely from the
limited data we have that improperly mixed
asphalt used in resurfacing the road in 1986
caused the problem.
And as for the fantastical claims of that
it’s a “substance humans can’t identify,”
this is more than likely simply because humans
never tried.